look we all love skins i know that you
like me have dropped way more money than
you should have on cosmetics over the
years and unfortunately game developers
know that so they're all too happy to
pump out a steady stream of skins
but just because they're expensive
doesn't mean they're good today we
wanted to count down some of the ugliest
worst most disgusting stupidest skins
we've ever seen but before we get into
that i just want to make sure you are
all sub to the channel if you aren't
already so please hit the subscribe
button and turn on notifications really
does help all right with that out of the
way let's get into it here are the top
10 ugliest skins in esports
strap in because we are starting off
this list with a hot one at number 10
it's the ak-47 fire serpent i think this
skin looks like garbage i think it's a
horrible derpy looking lizard painted on
it it's in a horrible mix of colors it's
green and blue you don't mix green and
blue and it doesn't even look good with
stickers or something like that it's
just bad all round before you come for
our throats we know that there are tons
of ugly skins in csgo this whole list
could be safari meshes and contractors
but that would be too easy and boring
hear us out the ak-47 fire serpent is an
extremely overrated and underwhelming
skin for what it is the way the dragon
is placed in the gun makes it look a
little bit of cockeyed also if you think
about it 60 of the skin is just a
standard ak it's barely different the
fire serpent is the most expensive ak-47
skin in the game and with that high
price tag you'd think that the most
expensive skin in front of the most
iconic and beloved guns in cs go would
be
well more than this
look this one is personal between me and
the fire serpent it looks bad at first
sight it just looks like a regular ak-47
then you notice a pattern which looks
like a lazily applied sticker while the
idea is interesting the execution is
lacking there are so many more awesome
ak-47 skins out there that don't cost
nearly as much as the 850 dollar price
tag the fire serpent's minimal wear
version has the only people who love
this skin are the ones who already own
it and i get it i tied myself at look
good too if i drop three grand on it
coming in at number nine is one of the
most pathetic skins out there rusty
blitzcrank look at this
so first time using the skin
it looks like normal blitzcrank but
rusty i guess
hence the name refund the skin yeah
should i ask the right for a refund on
this skin
now you might be thinking that's not a
cosmetic that's just regular blitzcrank
well unfortunately you'd be wrong not
like it matters because riot puts zero
effort into making this skin anyway
rusty blitzcrank was released back in
late 2009 and was removed from the store
shortly after due to its lack of well
anything the only way you can get this
skin now is by purchasing every other
skin in the game or buying an account
from someone who already owns it putting
any amount of money into getting the
skin is insane you get no new animations
no new textures no new sounds you're
literally paying for a slightly shittier
looking version of blitzcrank so it's
pretty funny though like it's just a
brown blitzcrank
and that's it there's no new effects no
neo anything it's rusty blitzcrank but
it's one of the rare skins worst of all
it falls into the seemingly endless pile
of league skins that have splash arts
that look way cooler than the end game
result
alright for our next entry we're bending
the rules a little bit because at number
eight we have not just one of lines
immortal items from dota 2 but all of
them dota 2's immortal items are among
the rarest and coolest cosmetics in the
game having a full set not only makes
your hero look like a badass but it's a
pretty good way to flex on the
competition that is unless we're talking
about lion because valve thought it
would be a good idea to make him look
like the infinity gauntlet between his
clashing red and blue arm pieces his
flaming mantle and golden fish scepter
lion looks like an rgb keyboard it's not
just that the colors don't match the set
lacks any consistent theme and putting
them all on together looks hideous sure
some of the items on their own can look
pretty cool but who wants to do that
adding to our list of lazy low effort
skins is ash's sidewinder and black
viper elite set fans were pretty hyped
up when elite sets started rolling out
we got sludge's badass mason tartan
hibana's mix of traditional and tactical
and of course copy taos beautiful afro
this one the capytow elite i gotta put
it aids here just for the fro because
that's just
that's
absolute chad vibes right there as for
ash mains though all they got was a
slightly dressed down version of her
default skin i mean they definitely
could have tried a little bit harder but
maybe ash means deserve this the ash
sidewinder skin
it's been
the worst skin in every one of these
rankings it's not moved every time i've
done one of these videos it's remained
in the worst position in last place
following that up is the other ashken
that also got released during the
outbreak event they're both trash
and one of them even got given away for
free so let's just skip over those
they're trash if you guys disagree
you're wrong unfortunately this skin
gets even more limp all elite skins come
with a unique mvp animation that helps
you gloat to the whole server when you
pop off and sure ubisoft has missed the
mark and made a few cringy win
animations
hey yo what the [ __ ] but there's nothing
weaker than this one
this set might be free but they couldn't
pay me to use it
busting a move into the number 6 spot
are straight fighter 5's b girl channel
e and b boy ryu
you know what i don't think this does
this any justice
i think this image
i think that image
is the one we should be looking at oh
boy where do we even start with these
skins not only are they insanely
obnoxious and don't make sense for the
characters or world whatsoever they're
also capcom's embarrassing attempt at
exploring hip hop and street culture
[ __ ] yuri's back oh my lord but yo we
got the homie b-boy ryu with the clown
with the flavor flake clock what
this yo
this is the path of my destiny damn that
street fighter money y'all ryu just
ended up looking like an absolute fool
but some fans found chandelier's costume
offensively bad but i guess we can't be
too surprised capcom has been known to
make some
inappropriate design choices
okay lord oh no wait what's going on
breaking into our top five is everyone's
favorite screen shaking butt plugs the
shadow daggers from csgo any knife skin
that makes your entire screen shake just
gets immediately put in in here this is
this is trash the shadow daggers are
csgo's interpretation of a push dagger
an easily concealable and highly illegal
knife that was favored by gamblers and
close quarter assassins i'm just gonna
really uh slowly if i go real fast you
won't be seeing what i'm going to do i'm
just going to demonstrate how you can
use this push dagger
you can
insert between the ribs
it goes right in unfortunately their
inclusion cs go is just kind of
underwhelming rather than two deadly
blades with an interesting history you
instead get a pair of plastic looking
fidget spinners that shake the screen if
you dare to play left-handed so you see
here when i switch my weapons it just
completely shakes the screen it's not
only for me it's also for my teammates
if they play left-handed and like it's
pretty much unplayable because
you have like a hard time looking the
screen so
if you're looking to buy a shower dagger
you should wait until they patch this or
you play right hand you should be
completely fine even a snazzy doppler
can't save these knives
taking our fourth spot is the most
horrifying entry on this list it's
mincemeat from fortnite
this outfit from a different
pov you got like flies on them and stuff
fortnite is an investor's dream it's
filled to the brim with
microtransactions and a young player
base that is more than eager to borrow
their parents credit cards for some
sweet skins but you'd think that a game
that attracts such a young crowd
wouldn't add the absolute abomination
that is mincemeat at first glance this
monster might look like an evil
blueberry pie but upon further
inspection of its innards and the flies
buzzing around its head you can quickly
tell it lives up to its name yes this
buttery pastry boy is a walking rotting
meat pie what kind of meat you ask i
don't know and i don't think i want to
comes with the mince meats
skit that looks terrifying
dude that should have been a halloween
skin that's actually look at his toes
bro
that is
terrifying it's got to be one of the
scariest looking skins i've ever seen in
this game the stir baby dude even the
back bling is like what
that's the that's the stuff of
nightmares just look at its creepy face
or the disgusting vein-like protrusions
and even more horrific is the meat sack
this thing flies around on but what
makes this edition even more
mind-boggling is that it was released
alongside this cute corncob guy why were
these a part of the same package oh man
we got the mincemeat skin this is
easily one of the most terrifying skins
i think i've ever seen he's got
look at
this coming in third place is a skin
that is so sad words barely describe it
it's vancouver amumu even though we are
based in toronto as a canadian company
we feel obligated to weigh in on ryan's
tribute to the vancouver olympics and
holy [ __ ] this might be the worst thing
we've seen in our entire lives this was
riot's attempt at recreating the
vancouver 2010 olympics logo and maybe
in some alternate universe where riot
put in a bit more effort this would have
been a lot better but it's just yet
another lazy skin with no new animations
or sounds it's just regular amumu with
each appendage being a different color
to match the inukshakaloka the least
they could have done was make moomoo's
textures look like stone so it would
actually somewhat resemble the iconic
inuit cultural symbol
second worst skin in gaming goes to none
other than cs goes gut knife i'm gonna
put gut knife at c and no i'm gonna put
a d i'm [ __ ] kidding get out of here
get out of here
i don't know why anybody would get a gun
knife anymore any cs go fan should have
seen this one coming the gut knife has
been getting [ __ ] on by the cs community
for years now it's been memed on for so
long that people are forgetting why they
don't like the skin in the first place
but then they see it in game and
everything becomes clear again it's not
exactly the weapon of an elite military
specialist it's more the sort of thing
you'd expect to find in the toolbox of
an overweight middle-aged hunter who's
busy watching that job he's doing on the
deer carcass he's brought in uh which is
probably why it never caught on in
counter-strike it's a weird girthy spoon
that is not nearly as intimidating as
the bayonet or even the flip knife for
that matter even a kitchen knife would
have made for a more interesting
addition skin elitist also bashed the
gutknight for being one of the cheaper
knives in the game all the knives are
rated based on their availability as
well so when the get knife came out it
was practically everywhere for a while
even people who did like it got sick of
it pretty quickly but if you happen to
be someone who revels in awful
aesthetics head over and grab yourself
the rust coat gut knife with the worst
float available and flaunt that garbage
with pride
finally coming in at the number one spot
on our list as the ugliest skin in
esports is valorance elderflame judge
yes you are seeing that correctly that
is an actual skin in an actual game
oh he's a chunky one
oh look at that oh
what's this this is egg he's just
grasping his own
egg
[Music]
dude that kind of looks awkward i find
it extremely hard to believe that ryde
didn't know exactly what they were doing
with this one
[Laughter]
shoot it when you shoot it looks kind of
looks kind of different when you shoot
it i can't lie this phallic auto shoddy
has been ridiculed by the valerian
community but some still love to use it
for its um
comedic nature hopefully they aren't
compensating for anything we're just
gonna spell it out for you this skin
looks like the gun developed a ball sack
and if you didn't see it before you are
never gonna unsee it now but guess what
the rest of the elder flame line also
sucks first off they are goofy as [ __ ] i
mean it's a cartoon dragon shooting
people it's a bizarre choice for the
first premium skin in valorem and
secondly in a game that's supposed to
have precise gunplay why would you want
a gun that moves and breathes it's
incredibly distracting
oh yeah no dragon skin i i would put the
dragon skins at d i hate the dragon
skins
can't trust anybody using the elder
flame skins but maybe most importantly
riot charges 95 dollars for these skins
95 to get a set that includes a gun that
looks like a dragon is tea bag in your
hands thank you so much riot
all right folks those are the ugliest
skins we've ever seen was there a skin
that wasn't on here that you were
sickened by the first time you saw it
let us know in the comments and i'll see
you in the next one
have you ever seen the [ __ ] like
cyber goth zarya skin
it's really bad it was like i don't it's
cyber gosh but it always makes me think
of those [ __ ] i'm sure you i don't know
if you haven't seen this i guess because
you're younger than me but like these
videos that were everywhere on youtube
and like forums and stuff in the
mid-2000s of like goth dance parties
outside they're so cringe
i'm sure those people are having a great
time i have nothing against them you
know the videos right
they're so funny